[Musique]
on a voulu créer cette revue pour créer
un objet qui soit à la fois un espace
d'exposition et à la fois un livre d'art
donc on a fait en sorte que cette
édition soit une édition détachable et
palpable le lecteur peut s'approprier
les œuvres les laisser dans un espace
libre et les exposés chez lui ou en
faire une salle d'exposition un projet
d'exposition
[Musique]
les deux premiers numéros étaient
adressés plutôt à des collectionneurs
d'art comme moi je suis une grosse
amoureuse du papier des textures des
matières on a voulu du coup en faire un
objet accessible par le toucher plus et
on a pensé à leur relaxer aux personnes
malvoyantes
[Musique]
les artistes nous proposent des projets
et nous on les on les réadapte pour le
livre là on a du coup travailler sur
pratiquement que des projets tactiles et
donc principalement en relief avec du
gaufrage des embossages un peu à la
manière du braille comme on le voit
souvent dans les expositions
les artistes viennent de tout milieux
donc il y a toute pratique artistique il
peut y avoir de la performance de la
peinture de la photographie
de des architectes il y a vraiment toute
c'est pas du tout fermé au niveau des
médiums artistiques
[Musique]